isn't it possible once you figure out
the origin of life that that's not going
to solve
um
that's not actually going to solve
the question of what is life
like is isn't it because you're kind of
putting a
i think that's the same problem but
you're putting is it possible that
you're
putting too many um
too much bets into this origin part
maybe the origin thing isn't
isn't there always a turtle underneath
the turtle isn't it a stack of turtles
because then if you create it in the lab
maybe you need some other stuff but
that's not the thing about the already
like you
like in the lab there's still memory
yeah yes right the experiment is already
the product of evolution right in some
maybe really deep way not an obvious way
in some very deep way so maybe uh the
haters are always going to be like well
you have to reconstruct the fold they
have to build fortunately for us the
haters are not aware of that argument
well no i know i know you're the one
making that argument usually but yeah i
just think that
if we create life in the lab it's not
obvious that you'll get to the deep deep
understanding of necessarily um
what is the line between life and
non-life no i think so there's so much
here i'm just saying playing devil so
much here but let me play devil's
advocate back in a previous conversation
right and say um
uh yeah i will why not i've got time
school cellular automata yes seller or
thomas are these these very
very um simple
things where you color squares
um black or white and implement rules
and play them in time and you can get
these very
very complex patterns coming out you
know there's nice rules there are
cheering complete rules and
um
and um
i would argue that so automata are that
are don't really exist on their own they
have to exist on a in a computing device
if that whether it's computing devices a
piece of paper an abstraction a
mathematician drawing a grid or
a
a a framework
now so i would argue cas are beautiful
things simple going complex but the
complexity is all borrowed from the
lithography the not numbers
right now let's take that same argument
with the um
the chemistry experiment origin of life
cat what you need to be able to do is go
and i'm inspired to do this to go out
and look for cas occur in nature
you know let's kind of let's find some
um some cas that just emerge in our
universe and for people just decide to
interrupt for people um just listening
and in general i think what we're
looking at
um is a cellular automata where again as
lee described there is just binary black
or white
squares and they only have local
information and they they're born and
they die
and
you would think nothing interesting
would emerge but actually what we're
looking at is something that i believe
is called glider guns
uh or or a glider gun which is uh
moving objects in this multi-cell space
that look like they're organisms
that have much more information
that have much more
complexity than the individual building
components in fact look like they have a
long-term memory
uh well while the individual components
don't seem like they have any memory at
all
yeah which is fascinating the argument
here is um
that has to exist on all this layer of
infrastructure right and though it looks
simple
and then what i would make the argument
i would make if i were you say well i
think cas are really simple and
everywhere is safe show me how they
emerge and substrate now let's go to the
origin of life where or machine i don't
think we want to do the origin of life
just any origin is good so we do so we
literally have our sand shaker shake the
sand like massive grid of chemistry
experiments shaking sand shaking
whatever
and then because we know what we've put
in so we know where how we've cheated in
the same way with ca we know how we've
cheated we know what the micro we know
the number of operations needed we know
how big a grid we want to get this
if we could then say okay how can we
um
generate this recipe in the lab and make
a life form
what were the what contingency did we
need to put in and we're up front about
how we cheated
okay say oh you had to shake it was it
periodic planet rotates
it's tried comes in and out so and then
we can start to basically say okay how
difficult is it for these features to be
found and then we can look for
exoplanets and other features so i think
sarah is absolutely right we want to
explain to people we're cheating in fact
we have to cheat no one has given i'm
i'm good at writing grants i used to be
i'm not very good right now keep getting
rejected but i writing a grant for a
planet in 100 million years no grant
fund there is going to give me that but
maybe money to make a kind of a grid a
computer grid
origin of life computing interpreter
space in physical space and just do it
so sarah said something which is you
can't
simulate the or engine of life in a in a
computer so like in simulation
why not
what what were your you said it very
confidently so yeah is it possible
and why would it be very difficult like
what's your intuition there
i think
it's very difficult right now because we
don't know the physics but if you go
based on principles of assembly theory
and you think every molecule is actually
a very large causal graph not just the
molecule then you have to simulate all
the features of those causal graphs and
i think it becomes computationally
intractable you might as well just build
the experiment
oh because you have in the physical
space you have all the
objects with all the memories yes
and in the computer you would have to
yes copy them and reconstruct yes yeah
that's a beautifully put and i would say
that lots of people
you you just don't have enough resources
it's easier to actually do the physical
experiment because
we are literally i review the physical
experiment almost like a computational
experiment we're just outsourcing it's
just basically we're just outsourcing
all the matrix
and algebra on your point about the
experiment being
also
an example of life it's almost like you
want to design it's like you know all of
us are
um lineages of propagating information
across time and so everything we do
becomes part of life because it's part
of that causal chain so it's like you
want to try to pinch off as much as you
can of the information from your causal
chain that goes into the experiment but
you can't pinch off all of it to move it
to like a different timeline it's always
going to be part of your timeline but at
least if you can control how much
information you put in you can try to
see how much does that particular
trajectory you set up start generating
its own assembly so you you know where
it starts and then you want to try to
see it take off on its own when you try
to pinch it off as much as possible
you